so much of my summer travel and talk
commitments and projects are either
finished or drawing to a close and I
haven't done it any of these 10 shorts q
and A's for a while so I thought it
would be a good idea for me to catch up
a little bit on some of the questions
that have been posted and provides some
some answers for them here are 10 more
they're all having to do with philosophy
in one way or another and they finish up
with one that's kind of funny at the end
so this is a particularly timely but
also timeless question asked by Jeremy
Oh Kelly and he's referring to people
like Neil deGrasse Tyson recently got
himself in a little bit of hot water and
scientists like like Dawkins and Hawking
who will say things like philosophy is
dead or philosophy is irrelevant and
he's asking where do you think this is
coming from and how would I answer their
claims that science has all of the or
will have all of the answers to life's
big questions so I would point out that
this is an issue as old as philosophy
itself you see this coming up in
Socrates discussion in the apology of
the trades people they know quite a bit
about what it is that they they know
about but then they they go wrong and
extrapolating that to the rest of
reality and science is particularly
prone to that because in the modern age
science in the narrow sense that we now
use it in becomes very powerful it leads
to technology and it you know has great
advances but it's also unable to be
adequately self-reflective about but its
own processes so it needs philosophy in
large respects without realizing that it
needs philosophy in order to fully
understand what it would it's up to and
since the time of you know sort of the
Galleon project that's that's I think
been lost to sight what's really
interesting about these these new claims
that get made is that they're really
just replications of older claims as
science advances as we you know move
from one one theoretical framework to
the next they do the same thing that
people were doing in the past so none of
these people are making claims radically
different than 19th century people who
are totally enamored of science they're
just being couched in different terms
Taylor Adams asks another question which
is not easy to answer in in two minutes
and is going to depend kind of on the
way in which we're understanding these
terms and the frames of references that
we're using so here's the question what
is the difference between philosophy and
science so let's make it a little bit
easier and put aside the social sciences
social scientists are constantly engaged
in the process of trying to figure out
just exactly what they're up to anyway
let's just talk about the Natural
Sciences the science is that really are
in large respect through technology you
know responsible for our modern world as
as we we now know it so one thing I have
to say at the very start is that every
discipline insofar as it becomes
adequately self reflective and is
carried out by people who are asking
questions like well what what exactly
are we doing here what are these
entities that were working on what's
going on with them it actually tends you
might say asymptotically towards being
philosophy and in fact many great
scientists have also been philosophers i
would say that those who are trained
these days in the fields that we call
the natural sciences quite often are not
very self aware of you know their
epistemological assumptions or at least
some of them some of their metaphysical
assumptions many of their moral
assumptions and you know what's the
difference well philosophy in theory
extends to all of reality science in
theory extends to the observable
phenomenal world and what we really what
we can measure what we can replicate if
we want to be very strict about it so
philosophy has a wider scope but is also
a lot Messier in in some respects than
science now a lot of that's going to
depend on your particular conception of
philosophy there many different
conceptions out there and there's you
know several different conceptions
is out there as well it should be
pointed out
so my my oft interlocutor 0 she flies
has a question about the term
post-modernism in philosophy is it a
useful coherent umbrella term or is it
used more as a label to try and group
disparate views and authors that are
hard to pigeonhole or a bit of both I
would say a bit of both the term itself
you know leotard if we want to be like
purists about it we'd go to leotards the
postmodern condition but very quickly
people started you know lumping all
sorts of other authors into the
postmodern so a lot of the people in
continental philosophy you know ranging
from Gary dots deleuze along with his
you know guitari shadow and Foucault
we're all doing you know quite different
things but are drawing on some some
similar authors as inspiration are
considered to be postmodern and then you
get you know friedrich jameson coming
along writing a whole book about the
postmodern and distinguishing between
different ideas of it so by the time
that you know we get to where we are I
would say even just a couple decades ago
the term had branched out so much that
it lost a good bit of its meaning I
think that the the idea that we use it
to pigeonhole or you know to group
disparate groups disparate views and
authors together is a very good idea a
good idea in the sense that that's
what's going on not a good idea in the
sense that we ought to be doing that I
think that a lot of people throw the
word postmodern around and they have in
mind you know this particular author or
you know the thumbnail sketch of what
that author is saying and very often
it's done in a pejorative context where
if you label somebody's postmodern then
you know they must be wrong or they must
be crazier they must be dangerous or we
should we should avoid them I don't use
the term much myself i actually prefer
the term late modern late modernity but
that's that's me
mark schmidt asks is there much
incorporation into philosophy as a
discipline within the west of eastern
thoughts and the simple answer that is
no not a lot and I would say what there
is of it tends to be pretty generic
pretty poorly informed by you know
serious study of the eastern texts and
traditions and thinkers but I do think
that it is getting better in part
because there's a recognition that we
want to engage in some comparative
philosophy there was this period for a
while where it was quite popular to talk
about the axial age you know historical
study has shown us that that was largely
you know sort of reading stuff into
history and kind of you know wishful
thinking because all these great sages
were not arising at the same time in the
same cultures and same context of the
same problems and many other really
interesting things were happening
outside of that that time frame work but
there's been a movement and I think it's
been spurred in part by multiculturalism
on this notion of you know we should at
least give other other cultures the
benefit of the doubt and check them out
and I think also partly spurred by the
alcohol at the second Rise of the East
meaning that that India China they are
you know not only powers on the economic
scene but on the cultural scene as they
used to be as it was through most of
history we're seeing the the West no
longer having the dominant position that
it used to hold her at least as dominant
I think that it's a good thing because
it leads us then to take seriously
what's going on not only in the
traditions of say Indian and Chinese
philosophy and I know there's more than
that but also in contemporary stuff as
well to look at the contemporary
developments not only in philosophy but
also in the larger
culture for example India recently made
part of its civil service examination
they have a component for ethics which
you know that's that's kind of an
interesting development there
so Devo Ovid asks me the question do I
have any favorite Eastern philosophers
if so could i discuss them a little and
the simple answer is no I don't actually
in part because I have not studied
Eastern philosophy in any really serious
way for probably at least a decade I had
a very strong interest than that as an
undergraduate and some interest in it
particularly because of philosophy of
language and looking at a Chinese
philosophy when I was a graduate student
and when I was teaching for ball state I
was teaching philosophy and religious
studies and the Eastern philosophy got
caught under under religious studies so
I was doing some research into into that
then mostly things having to do with
Indian and Chinese philosophy but I
haven't really devoted much much
attention to that for a long time and so
anything that I could really say about
that would be you know very generic I'm
not a specialist by any any means I'm
not even a particularly good comparative
'used at this point in time maybe I will
be down the line if I if I find the time
to you know dig back into those texts
again but that's that's not where I am
currently
here's a question from sk WB tm1 not
sure all that should be pronounced
actress the other why is it that hommen
Lessing and the Schlegel's are excluded
from philosophical discussions and
perhaps good too that's a good question
and is it because what they were doing
was inherently less philosophical and
more perhaps literary or you know
religious or something like that I don't
think that the answer to that is yes I
think that what often happens in
philosophy is that there there are you
know there are currents and people call
philosophy whatever happens to be in the
main current and they kind of ignore the
the other stuff if this were a hundred
and forty years ago very few people
would have heard of Kierkegaard and we
now know that he's you know major
thinker not only in terms of
existentialism but dialectical
philosophy as well you know people do
Studies on Kierkegaard and his
connection to Hegel to shelling to can't
you know all these sorts of things why
are these guys passed up well they don't
they don't fit neatly into the
narratives of the history of philosophy
that we want to we want to study they
are you know people do work on them but
they're there there's not a lot of
people doing work on them in philosophy
tends to be very specialized stuff i
would say that in philosophy itself the
fact that analytic philosophy which is
inherently anti historical and tends to
estrange people from any sort of you
know traditions of studying the text and
placing the thinkers in context and i
would also say continental philosophy
too in its own ways because it
established these canons of you know
here's the critiques and stuff like that
i would say that the dominance of those
two modes also tended to push a lot of
figures to the to the margins you could
also say this about people in other
editions like de Tocqueville you know
why Tocqueville is a philosophy why
aren't we studying in philosophy
departments why only in political
science departments good questions
Christopher Dunn asks a question about
saint anselm and it's does an some have
a hierarchical or flat conception of
free will and i would say Bothan either
because they don't think that these
categories are particularly useful when
approaching the will to begin with and
any sort of robust conception of the
will if you want to know what Anselm
thinks about the will then you have to
spend the time going through an Psalms
text and reading them very closely and
thinking about them Anselm says that we
understand will to mean three different
but connected things there's the
instrument the will is instrument there
is will as particular uses or occasions
or willings there is the will as affect
CEO or you know if we translate that as
inclination affection number of
different things and all of them are the
will it's not as if the instrument is
you know somehow more the will than
these other things and so you know if
you want to set up a hierarchy you know
with second order desires or stuff like
that Allah Frankfurt you can do that but
now you're doing Frank for it not not an
some the thing to do is to actually look
at the sort of things that Anselm writes
about in the the true the treaty sees
where he's talking about the will so
that would be you know everything from
the day very Tata all the way to the the
day Concordia and also including some of
the stuff that hasn't been translated
like the day similitude in a bus and the
dick Don sell me he has a very
interesting conception of of the will
which is you know I mean you can use
these these notions to sort of
illuminate them but I think it's better
just to like go straight to his
conceptions and stick with them the will
is complex because it is able to
self-determine but does that mean that
it's like you know radically free at
every moment no because the will can
also you know enslave itself to things
and that takes place through the the
modality of well that he calls effect co
so Terrence Rochin or roken says how do
you or can you say a person is obligated
to do something without them agreeing to
said obligation he gives an example here
of you know person ought to say someone
drowning in three inches of water if it
takes no effort but if they never agreed
to we can't establish an obligation for
them to do so so I mean for me this is I
don't believe that obligations depend
entirely on our having agreed to so
there's a basic level disagreement there
and I don't think most moral theorists
believe that we're only obligated to do
what we we've agreed to and I'd like to
point out you know a sort of conceptual
problem with that what would motivate
you to agree to anything if you didn't
already have some vague non you know
dependent on that sense of obligation
already operative you know I mean you
can try to do social contract theory or
some sort of Hobbesian egoism or
something like that that doesn't get you
very far and those sorts of moral
theories and you know capturing a little
bit of what we call ethics or morality
or ethical life or moral decision-making
but they end up so the end up leaving so
much out distorting so much that I don't
find them particularly useful except as
you know examples of how we shouldn't
think about things how how lower level
things lower level theories think about
inadequate theories so how can you how
do you or can you say a person is
obligated to do something without them
agreeing to that obligation we do it all
the time it's kind of a you know it's
kind of a I don't want to say silly
question but it's it's an off base
question we have some obligations and
then we can ask where is the source of
those they sure don't depend entirely on
our having agreed to them beforehand
so Taylor Adams asks me another question
what does someone who has a phd think
about counterfactual logic and I assume
that he's meaning this this PhD here
that ie me you know I don't have any
problem with with people using
counterfactuals in all sorts of
reasoning processes so if that's what
you mean by counterfactual logic that's
fine maybe what you mean by that is what
we call modal logic where we're dealing
with possibility and necessity there's
also some some projects out there to try
to derive something like a logic of
moral obligations you know there's
various names for that that sort of
thing but I don't have any you know my
metaphysics does not you know rule out
counterfactuals you could say so I'm not
sure quite whether the question is about
but I don't I don't have any problem
with the counterfactual logic
so we end on kind of a funny question by
jimmy page would you consider yourself a
genius just curious so the simple answer
is no and I'll go into that in a moment
I think if I if I were to consider
myself a genius that would probably be a
big mistake on my part but I'm really in
no danger of that because I've spent
enough time doing things that have been
difficult for me and encountering
obstacles and setbacks that you know and
also making dumb dumb mistakes that if I
had any temptation to consider myself a
genius at this point I would have plenty
of material to draw on to say no I'm not
oh I do think that you know there are
geniuses and I think that they're a bit
more you know there's that sort of
definition of you know IQ tests and
stuff like that even with that I didn't
make the cut off in the guy had 139 when
I had an IQ test when I was a kid and I
think 140 is the cutoff for that but you
know real genius is not so much about
about IQ it's about you know creativity
and making connections and brilliance
and that sort of thing and I'm fortunate
because many of the the people who I get
to to spend time with and work on our
the geniuses of history so you know
Plato and Aristotle and some Aquinas
Maurice blown Dale blondell Hagel even
you know a certain way Chaka Khan well I
like quite a bit they're all arguably
geniuses and I get to spend time you
know trying to delve into and then then
explain their brilliant insights I'm not
so concerned about expressing my own
even if I had any